cette question du port du tchador et
plus généralement celle de l'immigration
rebondi aujourd'hui le recteur de la
grande mosquée de paris demandent le
droit de cité pour l'islam dans les
lycées d'un autre côté la sphère de
beaucaire relance la polémique sur
l'inscription des enfants immigrés à
l'école plusieurs centaines de personnes
sont réunies en ce moment à bobigny vous
allez le voir elles manifestent devant
la préfecture de seine-saint-denis pour
demander la destitution de merde du
maire de montfermeil pierre bernard
avait refusé l'inscription d'une
quarantaine d'enfants immigrés dans les
écoles maternelles de sa commune
une attitude dénoncée par les
organisations antiracistes et le parti
communiste qui est à l'origine de la
manifestation de ce soir